at 42.3 last season with houston
sterling brown was 17th in the league in
three-point percentage
blocks malik fitz who played three games
on a 10-day contract with the clippers
i remember i did thomas young in his
career with that same kind of handling
quickness
there's a pass oh
blocks
[Applause]
porzingis steps in the passing lane for
the steal on the break doncic
instantly got the ball over to luca
turning in offense how about this heart
there you go kp coming up with it gets
it to the
music the musician
sterling brown and trey burke have
checked in for the mavs
porzingis the fall away over canard he's
got nine here in the first quarter
a match-up problem right now is kristaps
porzingis talked about that 25 a lot of
them was just like that one he just hit
reggie jackson that is
remember what he did against utah as
well but jackson is swatted by porzingis
this time when you ask coach borrego
about the marching orders for the mellow
ball in the off season game management
as uh
with a beautiful look that time of
porzingis for the dump
but what if ben simmons because there's
reporting out there the inquirer had a
piece basically suggesting that
he may not get between the lines in play
as porzingis hits a turnaround jump shot
horns have an entire week
another team that has a week before
opening night
big to big that pass from mcdaniels to
plumlee was a nice
but mason lost it
oh wow
inside two minutes to go here in the
first half the lead is 23.
doncic again
gets past three guys out to porzingis
and the three is money the help from
young now he loses finney smith to
porzingis he's lethal from the outside
and he chants it a triple a very heady
very unselfish
porzingis shot clock winding down
help comes porzingis that's tough
wow
herder on a bounce
hill denied porzingis the long arm
this is great ball movement again by
atlanta but this is great to see again
let's let them be rebounding
offensively especially
big swat by porzingis against chris
boucher
scotty barnes barnes in the lane before
the moment gets away
he helped keep portland's season
last year as porzingis launches and
rattles into deep three by gary trent jr
to point can wait for a minute
that one glances off the ram short and
vinny smith does it again with the
offensive board a flip by porzingis a
catch underneath had a bucket for dwight
powell timeout houston
things go the other way against him a
lot
match up
and then down the lane free to slam it
welcome back big fella the unicorn with
the dunk before that tatum three
it's 35-24 dallas a little over three
minutes gone by second quarter sean go
slam it home for the big fella
corey brewer an nba champion in his time
with dallas
averaging 13 points 10 rebounds three
blocks a game this year and it's big to
big on the pass porzingis out of the
post
beautiful feat here
porzingis to powell
boston has the last five points and knee
smith tried to save it and bounce saved
it right to porzingis who will turn and
let it fire okay
right to kristoff's porzingis who will
turn and drills a 20 this match
go right at that
porzingis across the lane
we'll look for the pass for the open
three ball corner pocket shooter frank
milikina
quick shot this time and one for
porzingis he's made two threes and now
three the old-fashioned way is possible
early in the second quarter
dump it right in there
size advantage by
kp
hanging tough some kind of way
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's when you know where a guy is
as far as his confidence is concerned
long three up top and it's on the money
for christops porzingis i'm presuming
this jaylen brunson
gonna make a play for them i really see
a lot of proviso east folks the last few
games doc rivers
saw javon carter the other day there's
porzingis on a good feed
by frank milikina and in the first 10
games of the season going into tonight
as well it also looks like a caruso show
that's a big basket
they're 13th in the league they're
giving up 12 a game so they've really
improved we'll see if they can maintain
it
as it's a thunderous dunk for porzingis
an excellent find that time by luka
doncic
and
dallas is going to have another lake
clock situation for luca to porzingis
another one for the logo
that's nice
good way to end a
you got to love it luca unselfishly goes
to kp
and the bank is open
well you were talking about those close
games
oh porzingis
that is they throw it up and throw it
down moment if i've ever seen one
hard away junior
porzingis
plenty of time knocks down the trifecta
and i've liked his confidence the last
two games he's been a different
porzingis to me and they're enjoying
their largest lead of what's been a very
tight ball game for the most part at
this point but they gets inside why not
you called it off
halfway through this third quarter
porzingis
it's been that kind of night but you
have to get something at the paint good
play by porzingis and he gets a steal
here and a breakaway porzingis on the
other end the easy tip just a great job
defensively take the challenge
offensively but also defensively active
in the passing lanes
fair
fair point here's porzingis for three
it's good porzingis
with his first triple and the mavs back
in front
got a good two for one here both teams
of the foul to give porzingis over paul
swishes home the three
[Applause]
porzingis
[Music]
nice fine brunson to porzingis for the
slam seeking their 11th straight win
here's brunson into the paint stops
kicks porzingis hits out of three
and i played with big guys that i'm not
making that pass to because they don't
they don't see it and they can't catch
it porzingis knocks down another three
they won a double team
[Applause]
porzingis turning and hitting over the
double
brunson missed a shot paul george
attacks they go back outside and mayor
coffey misses a three and hard away
there for the rebound for the mouse
harder way up ahead porzingis catches at
the rim to finish really struggling from
the three-point line as well two for ten
porzingis with paint protection
personified last time against paul
jordan at the other end rattles home a
turnaround jumper on the baseline this
goes back to what jason kidd said on
media day yeah week one reggie jackson
missed his first four shots now he's
made four in a row and they're all
three-pointers
porzingis fluffs the shot against paul
george got deep into the paint and goes
to the hook shot oh that's nice i like
that just like the patience right there
got into a spot a little spin can't be a
good defender
i'm sorry paul george a good defender
but doesn't have the size
to challenge the shot amir coffee
sneaking up behind paulie stein almost
tipped it away but the mavericks
maintain possession
porzingis from brunson for the flush
timeout clippers
knocked it in
jb attacking the inside
[Applause]
luca across court man what a pass to
hardaway porzingis
the big fella
believable play hardaway misses a three
and the unicorn his job clean up that
glass man playing big as a big
and getting results
over eight minutes or nine minutes i'm
sorry in the third quarter after having
picked up his fourth foul scored 15
points and here is a cut to the basket
and it's porzingis who found sterling
brown for a hoop inside
it is now seven straight games of 20
plus points for porzingis
the longest streak of his career
a lane to drive and porzingis blocks
paul george trying to dunk it
tonight's contest
and now he's going to drive it
and score
[Music]
missed three recent games with the
lefty and ankle trades as porzingis goes
to work that's a different basketball
player right there
why did chicago trade him to washington
last year they don't know why they do
that
they're not aware of why they did that's
good position that time porzingis
got the two right back for dowell yeah
that's a good look too by doncic any
abdia
who was the mvp of the israeli league in
makabi tel aviv before coming to the nba
he was guarding luca porzingis got away
and flashes a smile back in the other
direction
after scoring to beat the buzzer at the
end of the half cloud in the second
here's porzingis
man
what a display from porzingis tonight
the last seven games
dallas in front by eight at the half on
valley sports stay with us
[Music]
mavericks didn't stay in that small
lineup very long
[Applause]
position for porzingis double team
[Music]
it's awning good play
started out
nine and four
there's a cut to the basket defense
inside once again okoro disrupted on his
way to the round
great hands by porzingis early on
[Applause]
blows out
[Applause]
first of all
with the good defense good awareness on
the inside
over zealous closeout and allen got
allen that time he got
pocketed
and porzingis mobley at the round and
then jared allen double blocked by
porzingis as you take a look at the
mavericks defense
porzingis two blocks
65 games and started all but one of them
last season with new york powell
interior pass porzingis on the up and
under with the foul we're doing early in
this game two guys on him
white powell gets the ball in the middle
and simply turns and
[Applause]
accelerates up the floor then slows
things down
and luca oh just right around the big
man valencianas for the alley-oop to
porzingis
[Applause]
looks for him and finds him an easy
target to find 7-3 focus through the
star through the foul
great pass
now brandon a little step back gonna be
short herbs there but that spiked away
brandon after it and
that's a break
he's got bembry on top of him right here
here is porzingis with a minute on
working on kevin durant
out it goes
finney smith with a three season long
through the quarter pole here
and porzingis will shove it back in
on the road one of the best road records
in the nba this brooklyn team at 8-2
driving is hardened washed it inside
bullock in a foot race with aldridge
cutting finney smith
with the ball rotation in the drive
finish smith for three
[Applause]
luca operates on the bounce a pitch out
pass to porzingis
drive stops and he scores the basket and
count it with a foul on jared jackson ap
isolated
after the pass out
nice shot fake
he's been active with two boards
on this end of the floor so far in the
game
luca for three tipped to porzingis and
second chance points for dallas
well he just picked up his second uh-huh
and they need him
here's porzingis driving baseline and
cramming
memphis the southwest division leaders
with a five-game winning streak
and dallas trying to end that streak the
jump ball is controlled though by
memphis but taken away by porzingis and
here comes the unicorn
and now up top it's porzingis and he
hits his first three-point attempt to
the game that's good to see
before the game and he can stroke the
rock
he was a late lottery pick here's the
second shot opportunity porzingis again
from downtown
[Applause]
we're going to switch this play every
time you drop it right here jp's got to
go quick there you go
working against martin turn around shot
and off the glass
a couple of early rebounds for porzingis
as dallas has a 9-4 edge on the glass in
the first few minutes as porzingis takes
it hard to the basket lays it in with a
foul
runs and swings it
kp attacking the rim
tonight richards exchanged it with
bridges bridges got blocked by porzingis
then tried to pass it out to martin
reggie bullock stole it right on the
floor
first he guards the yard and then they
throw him a bone on the other end
porzingis really reading the offense
and you got to reward the big guy
bullock against bridges
orzingas driving on the rookie book
night and he hits the runner in the lane
i wouldn't have believed it and it just
points to the progress
that moses brown has made
as a young player great finish
i didn't go to krom but i knew whether
it was an eight-foot goal here
christopher's porzingis
the points for this maverick team but
the defense has been sensational as well
jim hardaway got under the defense
and a welcome sight but you know you
look at washington you look at houston
at his time at both places it was a slow
start for him
chris staff porzingis takes full
advantage of the mismatch you said mark
i i like double teaming him when he
faces up here porzingis just
that puts him in position for the
offensive rebound
blocked by porzingis his second
rejection
here comes burke
burke gets inside goes right at lebron
james
first math first foul on westbrook
just 10 second quarter points for the
lakers ali porzingis on a beautiful
soft pass from brunson
westbrook
can't finish he thought he got hit here
comes burke pushing
burke to brunson finds porzingis behind
the back
finney smith drives and lays it up and
in
reed comes way out on the floor to
screen for deangelo russell
vanderbilt leaps after the rebound
klieba advances it up ahead to porzingis
who waits for support here comes the
support it's hardaway who catches in
transition at the rim to score
and then it's porzingis nice find to the
cutter in transition along with patty
mills both dropped 30 on the lakers on
the road without k.d they get the win
that harden
a triple double as well so that's two on
the day 11 all time providing some
defensive porzingis there as well
porzingis statistically credited with
with the block for the mavericks
two minutes gone by in the game and
dwight powell knocks down the three and
the mavericks take a two-point lead
here's portland after the miss now
dallas wide open opportunity inside
porzingis
rebound for finney smith off the mid
side of the corner by lillard
it's brandon knight and porzingis and a
third has gone in
grand tonight really running this
offense well for the second unit for the
match they they need that with trey
burke out and nil akina having to start
as they finds porzingis for the slam
nice play by play about brandon knight
and running the offense so i think
brandon knight you're thinking gentry
heads to the bench with two personal
fouls chamezzi metoo and
he's charged with guarding porzing as
tyrese was on the switch and dorian
finney smith
king's only down by five
little mid-range jumper sterling brown
but right there is chris stapps
porzingis short little break for the
unicorn i mean how many lineups do you
think there are out there that has
someone uh
a 7-2 guy a 7-3 guy and then isaiah
thomas i'm not even gonna throw it out
there is it to make up for you know the
the deficiency there well you gotta have
your defense set and ready to defend
when you face
fox
nice pass and it's powell hooking up
with porzingis for the first dallas
points it's a great find here again no
pressure on this pass
clearly very productive for this
sacramento team which is a very good
offensive team kp
knocks down his second bucket that one a
three-pointer
james who just scored for sacramento and
here is green finding space in the
defense again 21 points
yep nearly five boards and seven dimes
porzingis and it will fall with a foul
heads up
[Applause]
nice pass by brunson
great ball fake
by the big
unicorn
a bucket he's the bottom five offensive
player
nice band
[Applause]
that's not a rand play that's just
simple basketball pick and roll
and kp
keep this up that's the way it goes for
a young team nice fine and poisonous
and puts an exclamation point on his
return to the floor
ending the first quarter with a
three-pointer
[Applause]
kitty blocked by porzingis and a loose
ball picked up by finney smith
you get stops you get out of the open
court paint protection
oh it's been outstanding this evening
nice pass and paint attacks
defending the paint on one end
and a tower of power
in the paint on the other end
and you get two easy buckets
[Music]
31 on threes 39 for the floor
this year
after annanovi missed the shot
right
touch pass by cleva under the tiger
inside porzingis and he drops the hammer
game over the last 10 for vanvleet
here's kp in the paint harp that's just
dorian making a smart play
[Applause]
nice
but tonight in the first half here in
dallas it's the euro step brothers 14
lead changes in the game the last one
courtesy of porzingis you talked about
paul from mcgee
cleaver right there
we have the outlet to doncic
good pass him
[Applause]
that throw right there lasers it in
porzingis finishes
balance comes to mind when i'm
watching devin booker's game
one shot outside is good
so they've gone a little bit cold a
spinner inside a second block by
porzingis picked up by doncic
[Applause]
cleva hold on for consengus
right over bridges and sailing in
presented by doordass
christos porzingis has his fingerprints
all over this possession gets the block
shot at one end and runs the floor
and the mavericks lead is seven
as morant on the drive
[Applause]
sixth straight game that they've had a
10-point lead at least
18. there's another block by porzingis
and he ties up jaren jackson feel it
they know it and they're letting
porzingis hear it this is a more
physical basketball team
vinnie smith met by jackson shot clock
at six
and five
away from adams has to push it knocks it
down
[Applause]
pass behind tillman picked up by josh
green racing with gorzynga's
[Applause]
he's down to 29
after shooting almost 38
last year
but that's true across the board with
these guys and he's back in there and
they're going to have to deal with the
present
we've got to get his dad in the hall of
fame amen
i've been on this crusade one of us is a
lot of years
yeah granting the whole thing and
deservedly so
tim hardaway was a five-time we haven't
seen him draw these assignments grant
until now it also looks like he's the
primary ball handler for his ball club
right now his last few possessions
[Music]
luka
their offense looking sharp everyone's
involved and of course the splash
brothers both are shooting well from the
floor here's porzingis and he'll lay it
in thompson's made four threes by the
way
collision against the suns in dallas he
played through it against memphis
as bullock lays it in his early action
defensively for kp dallas been very
effective
as far as being disrupted nice pass by
brunson
on the inside but maverick's using their
hands
simon's on the pick and roll nurkic
met by cleveland hit it off the side of
the board porzingis the rebound and
brunson on the push luca runs down the
middle can't get it to him to porzingis
trailing the play and hits the three
from deep
well they made a big trade for him at
the deadline last year gave up gary
trent
and oh there's a nice play beautifully
done dodge it's to forzengate every
night see him and who wants to stay up
late every night not me but anyway coop
they they've been on a hot streak too
that's an easy basket
inside for porzingis off of a nice fine
by bruncher
vinnie smith against the working chris
duarte out of oregon
and luca drops it in deep porzingis oh
it goes right around for an easy dog
and brunson again on the push duarte on
his hip
oh to the kite
give it to the big man when he runs the
floor like that